this show is brought to you by lyft
are you in between jobs and looking to
make extra money looking to save money
for the holidays whatever the reason is
you everyone needs to make a little bit
of extra money and the best way to do it
is by driving for lyft the ride sharing
app that lets you be your own boss pick
your own hours and earn up to 1500 bucks
a week driving your car
sign up today at lyft.com joey that's
lyft.com joey and we have a special
offer for our listeners
you get a 500 bonus when you sign up
using our show so go to lift.com joey
right now
right now and sign up to get your 500
bonus
shows also brought to you by
ziprecruiter
are you hiring do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidates
if you want to find the best candidates
you need to post on all the top sites
and now you can with ziprecruiter
post to up to 100 job sites including
social media networks like facebook and
twitter
right now you can post jobs on
ziprecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com charts that's right
ziprecruiter is offering a deal for our
listeners only go to ziprecruiter.com
church and post jobs for free
shows also brought to you by mvmt
watches i'm wearing their watches right
now i'm wearing the black on black it's
great i love it it's very light and it's
a great watch so when you go to
mvmtwatches.com
church you're going to get 15 off of
your order with free shipping and free
returns that's mvmt mvmtwatches.com
church to save 15 percent
show is also brought to you by onyx.com
oh [ __ ]
it's that creepy [ __ ] night
[ __ ]
i really don't give a [ __ ]
but i'm happy you guys are doing your
thing it's halloween [ __ ]
stuff is that if you thought that he
sat there and go when is the day i could
really lure kids maybe
halloween maybe i'll write a song about
[ __ ] halloween and [ __ ] and make it
popular
and do a video so [ __ ] kids could
come to my house and i could molest like
18 of them
instead of one that's a [ __ ] up i
can't believe people like parents have
to be careful like you have to be
careful on halloween like it's real
careful
it was amazing today
because i wasn't home all weekend i went
to vegas but i got home sunday and i
missed the trunk of tree trunk or treats
are a little safe haven don't get me
wrong there's got to be perverts working
somewhere there's always one do i feel
comfortable with my wife with her
walking you know my wife talks to people
she's very nice but you know
today was the worst today was obviously
the worst because today i got a knock on
the door at five o'clock i opened and
this kid's trick to treat and i go mercy
you want to go she goes hey let me go
with the kids it was like 20 kids
i go outside there's maybe like five or
six parents they're walking their dogs
you know same [ __ ] everybody wants to be
a movie star one parent's drinking a
margarita they just can't for the other
parents are dressed up i got a cowboy
hat i don't even have a host i just got
a [ __ ] gun
and my wife forgot to put the bandana on
me i don't even have a shirt i wore this
blue shirt whatever the [ __ ]
and i'm having a good time i met one one
of the parents goes to legacy one of the
dads oh cool
uh we walked down the corner and now
they wanted to cross colfax what do you
think we should do should we call across
colfax cars are zipping by
and i go
finally you know there's here's a bunch
of educated [ __ ] white people
you think they come up with a [ __ ]
plan with their 20 kids they're like
what what should we do should we cross
colfax meanwhile cars are zipping by
i got mercy by the [ __ ] hand like
it's my [ __ ] hand i'm connected by
super glue and i go can i ask you guys a
question why don't we just walk to the
corner and make a [ __ ] left and walk
all the way to the park and then walk
down and
after an hour of that you're done you're
good to go there's no reason to cross
the street the [ __ ] colfax it's the
same [ __ ] yeah they're young they don't
need that much they don't need that much
it's right on this side you know if i
walk from my house to your light and
back you're good to go trust me oh yeah
it looks close but it ain't [ __ ]
close it's it's a walk and a half but
now if we're walking in between those
streets on houses
you got 20 you're going to hit 2 000
[ __ ] houses oh yeah california kids
must
just clean up because that was a big
thing where i grew up they had like big
yards like every yard had every house
had like an acre or something
so like it was a big thing to forget
houses where i grew up here
it's every like what quarter of an acre
it's like nearly anything [ __ ] house
so i go let's just that we should we
stand on there from austin this lady's
just gone now it's getting dark now it's
just dark
and cars are coming up from everywhere
and they want to stay on the street
where the car is active i'm trying to
hit the side streets and cut down the
driveways you know those long you know
how every street here has a driveway
that goes all the way down you cut you
don't even need to hit the main street
no and some streets you could just hit
from [ __ ] driveway to every
every street in north hollywood has an
alley and they usually have them in
hollywood
all those streets have valleys and if
you really pay attention you could
probably go from one avenue to the other
one in those apps and those alleys oh i
do it all the time it's eight miles an
hour but you got no [ __ ] traffic and
nobody's cutting you off you know what
i'm saying you're constantly moving
so i'm in those alleys and i'm walking
and i'm popping up at the other street
we're not having any contact with cars
any contact with goofy people finally
one lady raises her hand she goes listen
i'm talking to my friend they're on the
church on laurel canyon
let's walk over and me and my wife just
look at you like it's dark out and you
[ __ ] ain't gonna be happy till
you walk across colfax are you with
these kids
you're not gonna be happy
until you walk across with these [ __ ]
kids
okay i'm i want me and my wife and
daughter turn the other way i thought
mercy was gonna have a couch with those
kids she's like [ __ ] them
yeah it's a lot of walking for them [ __ ]
those dummies and we went and hiked for
another hour me mercy and my wife in
fact more kids tagged along with us we
were on that side street because we were
by the park
we're by the park it's just [ __ ]
it's just common sense i gotta tell you
something lee
i'm at the point in my life where
i always walked around thinking i was
the stupid one
like i always walked around listen to
other people's opinions and listen to
other people's ideas and i would go why
are people doing that and for the last
five or six or seven years i've been
questioning that and i've been doing
just [ __ ] fine on my own do you know
that and it's like i've come to the
point that i wasn't as dumb as i [ __ ]
thought i was
for years i thought i was really [ __ ]
dumb and now i'm opening my eyes and i'm
like there's so many [ __ ] dumb people
around me and it's not even dumb like
academic dumb it's common sense dumb
and it's people who
you think would be mildly educated and
have a half a [ __ ] brain in their
head they both have parents they they
all went to college but lately it's like
i'm losing faith like i can't believe
that there's this
many dumb
on smart street people walking around
our [ __ ] earth right now or maybe
it's just this area i've never seen
anything like this i see it at the
airport i see it just in daily routines
it's um
we're victims of habit
but when something happens you get
alerted to that habit and you
heighten it and now you pay more
attention
people do not give a [ __ ] that's why
people will continue to get blown up
that it's it's just so weird well you
know when i see hit and run things late
at night i start thinking anymore like
that lady who got hit in a [ __ ]
wheelchair you know the guy should have
stayed and go listen i hit it
but who's out on burbank boulevard with
a [ __ ] wheelchair at three in the
morning i didn't even hear about this
yeah about three weeks ago they were
looking for a white van oh jesus christ
oh was it the bigger the big one on like
the not the wheelchair but like the
scooter yeah like a scooter oh yeah
she's always around she's always around
at 3 15 in the morning she's bound to
get hit eventually
don't she have friends to tell her but
anyway not to get away from my [ __ ]
situation here
i'm just thinking of myself for years i
always thought i was a dumb runner in
the room
and ever since i've opened up my mouth
i've realized that i wasn't that [ __ ]
done
i had to make a big decision last week
i had to make the decision that involved
more help
but for a month all i kept thinking
about was
what i was getting from my money
compared to the money that i was paying
out
and i'm not getting much i'm
i'm four thousand dollars off from what
they wanted
for what they supply me
and i'm starting to feel guilty that i'm
not using them
but i can't while i have a daughter i
cannot use these people
but their explanation was to me that
everybody
that wants to get to certain levels have
to use these people and i don't see it
i've never seen it for me right now at
this point what's going on in our
business right now
when you sign with a manager it's
basically to have somebody answer your
phone calls and call you and go this is
what's going on
and i really don't want that yeah it
seems like stuff will get a lot like
misinterpreted i don't want an answering
machine i can't pay you to be an
answering machine
i can pay you to do work
right i'll always pay you to work
but you're not paying your machine but
i'll pay you what you're worth
i'm not going to overpay you
for what you're supplying me i can't
overpay you when you're taking a message
from somebody
and somebody else is doing the work
right and that's understandable i just
can't do that i can't do that i don't
want to sign with a manager
unless i really need one or unless a guy
is getting me auditions every day and
i'm working
every day then i don't mind giving them
a piece of the package
but i just can't give you a piece of the
package for relying messages to me
you know what i do all the stuff myself
and i like staying on top of it i really
enjoy staying on top and it keeps me
shut
do you think
you need one like i know you said people
will say that but i think a lot of that
is just
even not even the status i'm sure a lot
of people say well there's a status with
having a manager but there's just people
just do what everyone else does it's i
think that's what a lot of everything is
you know when you look at these imdb's
these people have publicists and lawyers
on on staff and
listen bro that costs a lot of [ __ ]
doubt it's cool to have some people
looking
but you know what that cost at the end
of the year
those publicists
are basically the biggest ripoffs in the
world
yeah it's like thousands of a publicist
if you're thinking about getting the
publicist or you ever wondered what a
publicist does let me tell you what they
do they do nothing
they do absolutely nothing
it's like giving it's like taking a
dollar bill
and lighting it on fire and you can't
believe that these people have offices
because there's a little job and it's
called like the tonight show and
premieres and [ __ ] like that and these
people schedule like your cars
these people schedule like your radio
interviews
like you know they'll don't they'll call
these stations and they do some of them
do a great job of it some of them have
access to everybody
i don't mind paying you the doe
but i want you to call howard stern
right now at home
and tell him he needs to have me on the
radio station tomorrow at 10 to 9. if
you can't do that you're not worth your
weight in gold so you want the best yeah
you always want the best
but none of them could do that
when i go on your when i go on your
twitter page there's a publicist and you
have 10 000 people
i can't pay you any [ __ ] money
but they pop up every three weeks in
hollywood i get a request from a
different publicist and sometimes i [ __ ]
with them i ask them how much they are
you would not believe what the numbers
are
six thousand five thousand
a month a month
and you sit there and giggle
because there's nothing they can do for
you in this economy
what are they gonna do
get me on three more radio stations
what are they gonna do get me a cup of
magazine look at my face
what are they gonna do
i'm not gonna do nothing
most people use a publicist
let's say if you're
let's say if you want to be on tmz right
i could call a publicist right now and
say listen go to jerry's deli
call jerry's deli and tell him joe diaz
wants to make a reservation
and they'll have tmz there so when i get
there tmz will be there and i act
surprised it's crazy though because
that's what publicists do for people at
home that's what they're that's what the
new thing that they do out here is
some people want to be on tmz so they
hire a publicist
and they'll go listen
i'm gonna go down a [ __ ] uh the
comedy store like they're always at the
improv tmz
yeah the cameraman and if you want to
see him you could see him if you don't
you slip out the side door i don't see
him
i never see him i don't want to see tmz
they're not they're not
they're not nice people
they're not the nicest people in the
world really they're not no no not at
all
they'll start a conversation with you on
a nice edge it takes a certain person to
be those people they start a
conversation you're on a nice tone then
they push the envelope a little bit like
try to be cute and it's secured i don't
like
and you end up hitting them in the head
with the camera now you do 10 years of
time
so i just don't even like talking to any
of them
so yeah you just avoid i just avoid them
like the plague but don't you think like
the high a-list level celebrities if
they wanted to yeah stern could just
call themselves no well well
let's say
clooney clooney could [ __ ] do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants right with
this but this on a list is that i don't
know
maybe they they want to get exposed for
a movie like a movie's coming out on
friday so they want tmz to see him
somewhere you know there's different
there's a thousand different scams what
they do that's amazing none of them
which interest me that's the problem
right none of them would interest me
when i did grudge match they [ __ ]
made me hire a publicist it was like
throwing away my money
i fired that [ __ ] new year's day that
hook face [ __ ]
she was one of the ugliest women
she was the creepiest [ __ ] broad i
ever worked with in my life
and she had gotten married and her
wedding pictures were on facebook and
she made her husband dress on white and
he was no better looking than her
and they were all holding hands with a
bunch of ugly friends dancing around a
circle in hawaii barefoot and they're
all jews but they're the ugliest jews
like these are the jews that i don't
know what happened to them i feel like
you look at this stuff as you're signing
the checks just to piss you off what do
you mean like you look like the pictures
of on facebook you look at like the
stuff
before i checked her out i had to look
at her facebook and there she is dressed
in white she probably sucked 80 dicks
and there she is dressed in white in
hawaii she talked this poor sap
into marrying her and [ __ ] hawaii in
the sand
meanwhile some [ __ ] dirty white kid
from rocklin county he's been [ __ ]
her in the ass for the last eight years
she talked this [ __ ] ugly dude to
marriott and all her ugly friends and
they're in [ __ ]
hawaii you know holding hands spinning
around in a circle like somebody gives a
[ __ ]
you know
what was i thinking
and use that and listen to them usually
when people say i can't but i thought
the people at grudge match were very
nice and they weren't lying to me i
thought the requests were gonna come in
for some i didn't [ __ ] know
no request came in for nothing
i said she goes what do you want to do i
go i'd like to go to premiere and take
my seventh grade [ __ ] teacher
she goes i don't know if that'll [ __ ]
happen
she knows she goes and if it does happen
i'll have to you have to pay for your
hotel and hairware airfare
so what did i do i hit [ __ ] peter
siegel up on an email and he took care
of everything for me
yeah so yeah we paid for a plane ticket
i upgraded it to first class i think it
didn't really [ __ ] matter at least he
made an effort
i got a hotel myself
for two nights and they paid for two
nights or some [ __ ]
and i went to see grudge match with my
seventh grade teaching one of my friends
no big [ __ ] deal all right and i
fired her i was [ __ ] furious after
that because she didn't call me and ask
me how it went or nothing
so she always said to fire me you gotta
find me on the first i launched her
new year's day at 601 in the [ __ ]
morning
she called me at home yelling and
screaming i can't believe you opened up
my new year with this bad news listen
[ __ ]
when i [ __ ] got the plane ticket in
the [ __ ] hotel room for free you were
doomed
you were doomed you just [ __ ] saved
me
you you you weren't gonna cost me
[ __ ] a thousand bucks how can i pay
you ever again i don't even want you
around me you're just a lazy sack of
[ __ ] you didn't call nobody
they don't want to uh burn somebody's
things
you got to go listen this kid was in the
trailer correct yes he was okay we need
this plane ticket in the hotel room
we're not asking for much
bass playing thinking no biggie five six
you know what i'm saying just make it up
right run with them as they're doing it
they got the money it's paramount they
got the money
oh yeah they always got the [ __ ]
money you just gotta work him a little
bit that would be a real shame
that would be a real shame if a kid you
put in the trailer
you can at least give him a plane ticket
that that was that easy
i said mr siegel i just got to ask you
something
it's that time of the year the movie
gets released christmas day it's
december 18th the plane tickets are like
700 bucks
i want to know if the movie is like that
and you don't have to be embarrassed you
got to come to you
we put you in the trailer boom
i got a plane ticket in the [ __ ]
hotel for asking so she didn't ask me
she didn't ask she just called me and
said no they're just willing to give you
passes no they're not you never called
you [ __ ] hook faith [ __ ]
jesus and that's a job that she had look
at that that's weird that that exists
that because that seems like something
an agent could do or like you were
saying amanda and today all you need to
do is go on your [ __ ] twitter and
look that person up and hit them direct
all you need to do now to get ready like
in the old days you would hire a
publicist like i was thinking of hiring
my friend
okay i've hired her twice and both times
i haven't talked to her for 90 days
after that because she's that bad
she's that [ __ ] stupid and [ __ ]
and for some reason i called her up i
know she needs dough and i went to
paypal and i go hey i'm gonna send you
50 bucks to see if my paypal works
even fate [ __ ] her the paypal wouldn't
work to her email i go that's fake [ __ ]
i never called it back
when fate [ __ ] you in the ass i can't
call you back no the email specifically
to her didn't [ __ ] work
that's [ __ ] up it wouldn't even take
50 [ __ ] bucks at paypal so i knew it
wasn't met in the cards i didn't call
because i was in a higher effort boston
in connecticut to see if she could help
us with newspaper article or prank for
okay for foxwood since it's the night of
9 11 and i go you know what the last two
times i wanted a choker
and i paid her because i love her and i
don't i don't want to disrespect her but
i can't do it because there's always a
story and i'm not in the mood for
stories anymore and the paypal said no
paypal was like don't send them money
don't do it
don't do it
it must be weird hiring people
and having that like that responsibility
because yeah i can see i can see opening
the year of losing a gig is gonna suck
but that's not your responsibility
like
you can't pay someone just to be nice no
i have a [ __ ] three-year-old dog
those days are gone now those days are
gone at least i can't do it no more
i can't do it i used to like help people
out and stuff
and then people don't give a [ __ ] i
can't do it it's just
every time i've had a manager in this
town except jeff getlin
it's been a disaster it's ended bad and
at the end it just cost me [ __ ] money
they make out because they got paid
they always make out i fired them big
deal
i paid them for five months during my
hottest movie or whatever
and you're the one left with like the
bad taste in your mouth yeah because it
cost me [ __ ] money it was a mistake
that cost you paper is a mistake you
never forget
and then you do it again
and it wasn't that this guy is not a
great manager is that for right now
what's going on in my life
there's not much going on for him to do
the contract goes to caa he's going to
get us at the end look at it and go okay
he didn't call the club he didn't do
nothing
right so yeah that's an unnecessary
necessary thing unless now
he's got huge
television contacts
listen dog there's a new show on cbs
about new jersey i know they need a
garbage man
boom let me call the [ __ ] executive
producer i went to lunch with him last
week i'll take him out to lunch we'll
get a ride to the right you want a part
something
once a week even once a week he's worth
it okay he's getting me this he's
getting me that i haven't done a movie
in four or five [ __ ] years later for
[ __ ] years
2013 right at that grudge match yeah wow
three years three [ __ ] years you know
so
if you're gonna be my manager right now
my club work my comedy [ __ ] is taken
care of
i need everything else attacked
my company's taken care
and
i just can't give you guinness because
you look at a contract and say oh man
that's a great deal they're giving you
and it's not worth it to you to say oh i
have this manager or that manager no
unless they're no no no or any manager
no no i got a call from my agent today
i'm going to be in boston i love my
agent but i don't want him in boston and
i told him this 10 times i don't want
you around though
i don't want nobody around
i don't want nobody around
you know i want to zip in and out of a
place i don't want to eat dinner before
the [ __ ] thing
i don't want to eat dinner before the
show so you i don't i want to be by
myself for three four hours before the
[ __ ] show i'm pretty happy by going
to the gym and coming upstairs and i'm
very happy by doing that i can either
sandwich upstairs i eat light you know
but i don't want to talk to nobody
before a [ __ ] show you know it's just
the way it is what am i going to talk
about i got to go to dinner with you for
an hour and then i got to talk to other
people on stage where the people that
matters
the other people that matters the people
that are paying to come to the [ __ ]
show are the ones that deserve my focus
and my conversation
not some agent or a friend of mine that
i gotta go to dinner with before the
[ __ ] show or talk to two hours before
the show
i don't wanna talk to nobody you see me
in the green room we sit back there we
smoke a drone we don't say much no it's
just me and you
there's no that's it when you come to
austin no i don't even want the tv i
don't want nothing i don't want no
movement
i don't want no movement around me
i just want to relax
i ask you simple questions you give me
simple answers and you do the same
i.e what's the color of the sky today
blue that type of [ __ ] anything about
anything anything out of that i don't
want to really [ __ ]
there's nothing to really talk about i
don't want people around because
after the show after two shows what i
want you around for
to talk to me about what to ask me more
[ __ ] dumb questions i just did two
[ __ ] shows
is it weird because it it yes it's weird
that's work for you like that's that's
like your work week yes i don't want
nobody to [ __ ] around
i don't want nobody to [ __ ] around
you and i we do this you have an
understanding you're a fan of comedy you
walk around
i'll stay back there by myself
i don't want to answer no question to
talk to nobody or be involved in a
common [ __ ] session i want to be
involved in the conversation four
minutes before i go on stage
four minutes five minutes before i go on
stage as i'm going to the stage i'm
gonna bump into you briefly and converse
with you for two [ __ ] seconds
and hopefully you have like a pair of a
turban on
or a pair of shoes that [ __ ] bother
me so i can say something to you to your
face get aggravated enough to walk up to
the stage and now i have a purpose do
you love confronting people like that
like i hate you
like if you know them i guess
sure if i know them i'm saying really
you gotta wear this [ __ ] tonight i'm
doing a show and then they'll know
they'll know what's going on people like
rogan arie duncan no i gotta get fired
up before i go on stage i don't want to
pick a fight with you
but i want to ask you what the [ __ ] is
going on with your head that you got to
wear those [ __ ] that t-shirt and all
that [ __ ]
dumb look on your [ __ ] face or
whatever the [ __ ] is going on
i need that i need to get sparked you
know i need you to get like
put ranch dressing and walk into my room
you know
and just
and and what is that is it you can feel
it when you go on stage you have more
energy yeah i just need five minutes of
somebody aggravating me i don't want an
hour ago man that just brings me down
okay so so you'll start it like you'll
initiate the conversation then okay yeah
no no you'll initiate it by wearing
something or saying something [ __ ]
stupid
two minutes before i gotta go on stage
not you personally where the [ __ ] wants
to come you know oh okay i thought it
was me i think
sometimes you got to do a bong hit mid
mid podcast it's a halloween podcast
smells like snickers
i didn't eat a lot of chocolate no i
love snow no i think i ate one piece i
had licorice
she gave me a stick of licorice last
night mercy's cheap with the [ __ ]
candy you know she's not like she's
gonna give you a bunch of she's got her
eye on it she gave me some goldfish when
she took them back
she had two of them slobbed them up and
tried to give me sloppy [ __ ] goldfish
i don't need this [ __ ] goldfish covered
in the flu
what about tonight when you go home like
we my brother and i always used to hide
our candy oh yeah she's got the bucket i
just saw it when i went back to pick up
that stuff
she's got buckets everywhere that [ __ ]
she's got two buckets of candy
yeah and this could be worn by them like
that's that must be the best part about
being a parent
as i was leaving this evening she was
sitting on the chair
and she had already eaten a bag of mlm
peanuts or something and chocolate was
dripping down her face and over here
and she was chewing on something and she
was just about to open up another bag
and my wife grabbed and go one more bag
then we put the rest of the candy away
till tomorrow she was cool with it
yeah he was cool with it that's it i'm
happy for her she had a good little
halloween she had three nights of
[ __ ] trick-or-treating damn and she
had she had trunk or treat one night at
the church and one night at the [ __ ]
school
who the [ __ ] knows lee i don't i don't
you know it's it's
i'm baffled by all this i'm still blown
away that i'm a parent never mind doing
calmly never mind doing a [ __ ]
podcast
i walked around with a face like a
cowgirl with a hat i'm looking at her
walking with 18 other kids
in the middle and then and every time
she bumped into a kid a hat fell off she
had to stop and pick up the [ __ ] hat
she didn't give a [ __ ] she put the hat
right back on her head
so i'm learning from her
i think as much as she's learning from
me
i'm learning about myself from her as
much as [ __ ]
she's learning about me i guess so it's
a pretty interesting part of my life you
know
i know you were nervous about having
mercy later like
being a little bit later i guess than
you usually do
but it must be and not even just with
you but it must be so cool for kids to
have like
parents who actually have like actual
life experience
because like i can't there were kids my
their kids my age who have 10 year old
kids and that's great
but what what if i had been teaching
someone for the last 10 years that would
have been terrible
so
i'm having a really good time
you know she's three and a half and uh
it's great i'm happy for
she goes to school four days a week you
know she got the [ __ ] activities
but i think about the other side of that
i think about like um
i'm having a good time with her
i've never had this before in my life
you know i've never had this uh
calm this
[Music]
you know a couple weeks ago i had to cut
you know clear my schedule for
and i gotta tell you i was angry for 18
seconds
and i understood where 10 years ago i
would have been angry for an hour
and then i would have came to terms that
eventually she would have warmed my
heart this time
i was okay with it for 18 seconds i go
damn i can't do that you
[ __ ] it this is what it is you know
i've accepted those little things you
know uh
i'm still ashamed a lot of people
that
don't understand my situation
you know why don't they understand it
do i have a schedule
and i don't break it for nobody
i have a schedule i know what i want to
do every week
and sorry this is what i want to do
i have this type of time to [ __ ] around
tomorrow i got jiu jitsu
i got something at 3 30 and i got
something from 4 to 5 15. i'm going down
to do a spot
and i'm going to meet shane
and we're going to taco and talk about
pitching and [ __ ] like this you know
like not baseball pitching but pitching
this [ __ ] stupid thing we're trying
to write
and that's what i want to do you know
wednesday i listen i ain't going to
hollywood wednesday day i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm going to i'm going to drill
class i'm going to jujitsu and i'm going
to [ __ ] whatever thursday i might go
to hollywood in the daytime and take
care of a few things there's nothing on
the spot at the store
friday i'm not going up over that
[ __ ] hill
saturday i haven't decided yet that my
babysitter let my wife go to a movie at
night or something just to get her out
of the house she's been in the [ __ ]
house for the last three weekends
you know that weekend i came in that i
was supposed to watch the baby and she
was sick
she didn't get to do anything she had
been home for six [ __ ] weeks
so maybe i was just thinking maybe
staying home one night this week let me
go to the movies go get coffee whatever
the [ __ ] she wants to do
you have to give them a breakthrough
they can't just sit in that goddamn
house you know no jesus i'm starting to
lose my that's the only thing that's
bothering me right now in my life
my location situation i don't know if
this is where i want to stay yet
there's a lot of variables in my life
but
i can't stand these [ __ ] people
the joke is becoming a reality every day
i hate one more person
they drive me crazy
and the good lord knows i try
now
do you think if you
didn't have a kid you maybe wouldn't
care as much you just stayed here
because it's work
no if i didn't have a kid right now
i don't know
but the still the
the thing is
everything still applies with me like
i still don't think i could do a winter
in the east coast
i think you i think after after a couple
weeks you get used to it it's terrible
but it's not that bad
and trust me i hate snow
but
the only the only issue for you i guess
would be the traveling and that's a huge
issue that you need to get out of every
week
but
for me
i don't think it'd be that much of an
issue unless you just flew march till
[ __ ] october
and told everybody to suck your dick
work locally
two weeks a month that that's the other
option november you work in jersey
december you work in new york and
january february you work in long island
in boston yeah you could do that work
with the amtrak schedule yeah that oh
that amtraktoria
and then march start going back on
planes and [ __ ] so you could that's one
that's that's a great plan lee i never
thought about it that way
yeah it could work it's uh
i'm nowhere near ever like having kids
like that's not in my future right now
but i see what you're saying always
remember
nothing's ever in your future
right that's true nothing's ever in your
future
nobody [ __ ] goes home and goes
tonight we're gonna make a kid
and by next year you know nobody does
that a kid always comes surprised i mean
really you think it's mostly a surprise
well no some people you know there's
some women who whatever ovulate whatever
they ovulate and they gotta get [ __ ]
that [ __ ] night like a werewolf or
whatever i thought most people didn't
like that i have no idea i just always
assume some people do it and all of a
sudden people knock up pregnant and and
you know next thing you know you gotta
you gotta adjust your life in nine
months or to think what you have to
adjust to your life for life to be like
and it's really no major big [ __ ]
deal you wait you wait you wait you wait
it's so funny
i always reference a movie
that i saw and that's the thief
there's a scene with james conan tuesday
well the diner
and he tells her about this thing that
happens to him in prison and what's
supposed to happen
and what he did and what happens
and he goes you know what nothing
happened
for all this time i stressed out this
situation that something was gonna
happen
and at the end nothing happened
and it's the same thing with anything in
life you just pick it up and run with it
and you
learn as you go along but if you sit
there and look at it from an outsider's
eye and start reading books on it
you're gonna get all caught up in
[ __ ]
oh yeah and that's what i didn't like
like a lot
i think parenting comes down to a lot of
common sense i think a lot of [ __ ] comes
down to a lot of common sense
i
there's things i see that i can't
believe i
but i'm not smart and i'm the only
person who sees that
right so you think you're not this
they're not the smart one and you see it
so why don't these smart people see it
well these [ __ ] people were supposed
to walking around acting [ __ ] smart
with their little [ __ ] hats and their
little [ __ ] dogs and [ __ ]
make them believe like they know
something about life why are they acting
this way
that the fact that they wanted to walk
across
that and lee
at 6 30 it's busy by hollywood high oh
yeah lee it's [ __ ] busy over there
and those people were driving past the
colfax i'm sitting there going why am i
why is my daughter walking towards
colfax
and i even tried to turn down the alley
and they kept going to [ __ ] colfax
then the dad got into the middle of the
street like to stop traffic and cars was
still whizzing back him [ __ ] you you're
not gonna stop for a random guy
oh i hate when people do that
what is exactly what happens yeah they
think they're a crossing guard yeah next
thing you know that he's like kids
coming i'll say your kid gets whacked by
a [ __ ] car [ __ ] you i couldn't
[ __ ] believe i'm like terry what's
going on here no no excuse me why don't
we walk down to the corner and make a
left and then walk around and they're
like oh my god that doesn't sound bad
like look at those first three houses
the people on the porch is waiting for
kids and you guys want to cross the
street
and
to me like i can understand where it's
like okay well there's the crosswalk
it'd be okay but every other day like
i'll just today in van nuys there was a
police chase
and like there's always crazy [ __ ] going
on and and like why take the chance you
won't stop for nobody either all right
that's what i was [ __ ] going crazy
oh no but dude i
i wouldn't go out before paula i
wouldn't leave my house on saturdays and
sundays
and go to like
at all but especially to ventura
boulevard like i
it makes me so uncomfortable like when i
go we're going back to boston i was
single for a long time in boston i used
to hate going out friday and saturday
nights because it's when all the drunk
people all like the people who go
and all that like all that stuff which
is great it's fine they're young and
having fun i did it a couple times but
i'm not that kind of person
and then those are the kind of people
who bump into you who walk into you
because they're looking at their phone
and i i just avoided it
but yeah you can't live in your house
the whole your whole life so
it's a struggle
it's like a jungle sometimes it makes me
wonder how i keep from going under
no i
i just uh and i think those people are
everywhere now like i don't think
like let's say you move somewhere unless
you like live with family or certain
people like that like i think those
people are just
i think everywhere is the same now
i think that's what i'll tell you what
i've seen last weekend i'm still baffled
and we talked about it
rogan and i talked about it for 30
minutes before the podcast started
and then we didn't talk about it anymore
during the podcast we talked on it
and i was really starting to think about
it okay so i'm doing mma junkie okay
radio i want to thank those guys george
and his brother ghost
for putting me on friday morning to
promote my show in vegas
stitch duran was on i had a great time
but while i'm sitting there we're
talking about the then moving the
raiders to las vegas
okay and he goes i go so where's the
stadium he goes basically right across
the street
and i go so wait a second
they're gonna put that [ __ ] stadium
in the middle of all this
so it's near the strip yeah
oh no
that's gonna be there's gonna be a lot
of people dying there i i so i'm
thinking to myself listen
i i watched the raiders when they were
[ __ ] nasty
in the 70s with matuzak i liked watching
all that sickness and
and then big john madden was the coach i
still remember that being a [ __ ] kid
you know and then
the guy hit the guy on monday night and
crippled them i think
i think it was a monday night football
game you know less than molester i loved
all that [ __ ]
but it became something else again i
don't mind watching the football game
but when me and legal was 7-eleven and
there's a guy in there with a raider
tattoo all over his [ __ ] head and his
neck
you know i mean
i don't know i don't know
so
like the raiders is another aspect to it
i'm just saying having an nfl stadium
right next to the strip with all that
alcohol all those people
and two teams one team lost that's not
going to be good
the raiders i i've only heard about it
like when they when i was just watching
football they were good like rich cannon
i think they won a super bowl
around when i started like paying
attention to football but i've only
heard about like the craziness that goes
on there have you been to a game there
no
no no no no but i know what happens at
these games now and every week i wake up
and i see a video or they talk about the
news about an argument at a football
games these rams
came along you know i told [ __ ] bert
christ i can't believe you got season
tickets and you bring your wife down
there
you know what if there's somebody
[ __ ] hit your head your wife in the
head with a [ __ ] bottle because you
want to go to a stupid [ __ ] football
game
my friends got season tickets he always
asked me do i want to go down there
i just don't want to go to a game and
get hit in the head
because i'm there trying to enjoy a
[ __ ] game i don't think they're smart
anymore
you know you say you went to a game and
you got up to get hot dogs and the guys
are talking to your girlfriend yeah you
know and it's just i'm not in the mood
for all that [ __ ] anymore in my life
i don't i didn't see that at in boston
i'm sure it exists so
somewhere i think maybe it's just the
bleachers
i think i think maybe it's just worth it
to pay to sit in the nicer places
sometimes but even then what are you
gonna do on the way out like it's the
place now where that rams are and the
place where they're going are not fun
places to be
but they're gentrifying and then an
engelwood eventually and it's gonna be
next to the forum correct yeah yeah yeah
but it's not gentrified right now
and neither is the usc area yeah but let
me ask you this when is the what is the
proposed opening for this stadium i
think it's like in two or three years
but let me check okay in two or three
years
they're gonna have more [ __ ] they're
gonna have bet bad and beyond down there
oh yeah when you want to chase black
people out of your neighborhood you
don't call the ku klux klan you put a
bed bath and beyond in that [ __ ] name
but nothing scares black people more
than bed bath and beyond
they read that word beyond and that
[ __ ] with black people that word beyond
they don't like that [ __ ] beyonce i'm on
but beyond i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about that's all that's
what's gonna happen guarantee you want
to scare the [ __ ] out of white black
people bed bath and beyond
not subway there's other firestone
station
that's fire bread [ __ ] bread
you'll go in there i went there
no no you don't even need to go in there
you can tell
it's a chain that's making sandwiches
they're going to cut edges and give you
shitty coke cuts they tell you the
coconuts are good but the cold cuts are
garbage and the bread's garbage that's
what the whole thing about these
sandwiches anymore is the bread is
garbage
this is my problem the firestone one is
apparently they steam it and the owner
was there he was nice but he was like
hey man you probably shouldn't take that
to go
because we steam it so by the time it's
gonna get all soggy i was like [ __ ] you
i'm like that's what you're doing this
is my sandwich steam like i want my
balls licked by a [ __ ] cat with it
with sandpaper
dante gazzini showed up
the other night in las vegas looking
like [ __ ]
michael corleone's driver
nice he lost a bunch of weight he looks
good he looks good i didn't get a chance
to talk to me no
again
i don't want to do dick before show and
then i'm going to do dick after show now
basically after a show i just talked to
people for two [ __ ] hours and i just
sat down for 45 minutes and i got back
up for an hour which means every muscle
in my [ __ ] leg is sore so after the
shows i want to sit there and talk to
these people and take pictures and [ __ ]
around dante and his friends were very
nice enough to invite me
to dinner
and i tried to tell dante that friday
nights we usually go out with mario's
son remember danny oh yeah of course
danny comes and we shoot out we just go
get a dinner at his house or whatever
you can human for whatever the [ __ ]
but it just so happened
that i
just shook dante's hand
when i went outside that night danny
called me and said i'm not coming friday
night i'm coming saturday with my dad if
dante would have hung out i would have
probably ended up to go eat with him or
he would end up going with us over at
the clam
because we usually go to that [ __ ]
seafood bar right yeah but we were there
till 10 o'clock talking [ __ ] again
you know the show ends at nine and
you're out there till nine ten ten
thirty talking [ __ ]
you know how it is when you after a show
you people go to the show
some people wanna smoke with you
whatever i ain't smoking with people i
didn't take nothing somebody did bring
me candies
but i didn't take them till the end
because now i'm scared because they
threw you out they got everybody under
the eye and if they threw you out they
want to throw me out next so i'm like i
ain't taking nothing from [ __ ] nobody
i wouldn't even take a kiss from [ __ ]
people nothing
but uh people missed you you know that
but i still like the south point okay
the reasons why i like the sound point
is for all the reasons we discussed i
know exactly what i'm getting i got a
good breakfast i got a good lunch i got
a good piece of coconut cake i took
three bites and threw it away in the
garbage i didn't even have a coconut
cake this year yeah not the strawberry
shortcake no no no no i wanted to switch
it up a little bit every once in a while
i gotta switch it up but it's funny
i got to see our good friend larry
larry's dynamite guy and
i said to him listen tomorrow swinging a
kid by
but after radio i went back to the room
and got stoned and fell asleep and
i go just bring him up to the room and
he came up to the room and steve simone
and larry had this boy up there that was
his 10th birthday
that [ __ ] made me feel better than the
[ __ ] shows you know seeing how happy
larry was this kid was you know i'm the
meatball king of [ __ ] fox or whatever
the [ __ ] i was on yeah his kid and he
supposedly
comedy and stuff you know steve simone
has this family friendly comedy i'm
listening to it the other and i'm like
these people are having a good time
right now they're about to run into a
brick wall with me he's up there talking
about ice cream and dreams and [ __ ]
pajamas and [ __ ]
and i'm about to go up there and talk
about [ __ ] copernicake
you know so
where's that [ __ ] uh
music you were gonna play there
monday october 31st
that's what it's all about let me give
some shout outs real quick happy
birthday matt holmaire
joey alvarado the [ __ ] kettlebell
king
got some article printed me and rogan
we're talking about them on the podcast
today
if you really want to get in jiu jitsu
shape with [ __ ] kettlebells joey
alvarado is your man
brandi lynn always looking good with a
new joey diaz [ __ ] uh pirated shirt
art porn
chris o'hara
thomas
eagle lorne rosenker and jeff skinner i
love you [ __ ] and don't forget
60 tickets left for the wilbur theater
in boston next friday tons of tickets
next left for uh november 12th at
foxwoods what's up lee oh no it's it's
down to 40 something now i checked
really yeah so get your tickets fast 40
tickets left at the world bethina
and i'm not adding those shows i ain't
that [ __ ] type of monster what you
got is what you got [ __ ]
allie wong sold that [ __ ] they got a
great liner oh yeah wubba theater ain't
[ __ ] around bro they got a good
lineup the last time i the last time i
was there probably six or seven years
ago to see russell peters those [ __ ]
yeah yeah
they've always had comedy there but now
it seems like they're focusing on it
well they're going after a different you
know echelon or whatever i i don't know
i like to laugh boston i have nothing
against lack boston i think laugh boston
is a great club you know the agency just
wanted me to move up and do this theater
so i said i'll do it one time and see
how it works out i didn't do it i didn't
think i would do well
i just wanted to prove to them that you
know i didn't know what i wanted to
prove and i lost so
but i'll uh give it a shot and see how
it goes i'm very excited about that
it'll be fun do you mind if i talk real
quick about the uh old episodes
not good so guys um
there used to be a limit on how many
podcasts you could have on itunes only
the most hundred episodes everything's
always been available on our rss feed
but real quick what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna release them all but
some of you have it set on to download
every episode
please don't switch it to have it only
download new episodes because i'm going
to re-release everything but i don't
want to kill anyone's data plan
because i opened it for a couple hours
we got a bunch of downloads i was like
oh [ __ ] uh so if anyone
uh
is
just check your subscription and we'll
be on the lookout i'm gonna do it uh on
thursday morning i guess
and or wednesday i'll do it wednesday
morning
and just be on the lookout for it and
that now that just means for everyone
else that all 400 whatever episodes will
be available on your phone
i'm [ __ ] believable [ __ ] look
at you
re-releasing like ricky and desi yeah
lucille ball and [ __ ] like that so yeah
wednesday morning 9 a.m
pacific i'll do it i've been having a
hard time lately because
i've been getting into this [ __ ]
cellu show on uh
on netflix i'm up to you know i don't
watch it for a few days and i watch two
episodes a night for three nights or
something
and i'm up to episode i don't know 20
something right now fidel took over
and it's so weird to see this island and
and first off i have to congratulate the
writers of the show they've done a
phenomenal job so far
i told my wife if they mention union
city new jersey
i will [ __ ]
shoot myself in the head i'll have to
contact these guys because they really
did their homework
so it's a show about a cuban singer but
right now at this point castro has taken
over
the girl that was getting sexually
molested by her stepfather has left and
gone to new york city and she's a
successful singer
the
young cousin to celia cruz is now
homosexual and the cuban the castro
regime just beat him up
because i told rogan about this 15 years
ago that
uh
when the castro regime took over in the
beginning they hated gay people they
were killing gays
throwing them out of ships with [ __ ]
tied their hands and [ __ ] there's tons
of stories about the fidel castro regime
did to [ __ ] jesus christ gay people i
mean it's
there was so much going on in this tv
show that is on point
you know the racism that was in cuba how
they tried to threaten celia cruz
to leave the band because of the color
of her skin they said she won't sell
records because the owner of the company
his name is sydney siegel
he's a jew but he speaks spanish he's a
cuban you're gonna say that's a pretty
jewish name sydney [ __ ] seagull
that's a great [ __ ] name but i also
notice that not once do they call him in
julio
the jew i don't understand why and they
say mulatta they say
they say slang words on the show it's
all in spanish
but it's in uh
it's in uh whatever the [ __ ] you call it
when the words come up you know what i'm
saying i i listen to it and i'm really
enjoying the spanish because it's it's
60 percent cube in spanish do you think
they would have called him just the jew
to him he would have they would have
called him the jew behind his back they
called her calling him
because cubans do that [ __ ] they they
just say julio they go by nationality
but the point i'm trying to make that
what's really weird about this show is
the religion that's involved in this
you know whether it's the santeria side
or just praying to the saints and
what this you know when my wife said
look at that
person she couldn't be anymore when did
the irish invade cuba my wife said it as
a joke
and i looked at it straight in the face
and i said what do you mean the battle
of the boy
when the irish that didn't want to fight
wanted to leave they went to the only
other catholic country
cuba is known as a [ __ ] catholic
country
that's it
that's it it's a catholic country you
know so
all these irish went there
and there's a chinese check in the show
to really show the
the different ethnicities that ended up
in this island it was like an island the
[ __ ] pirates
that now had flourished and they had
gambling they don't show the gambling on
this show
which really baffles me but it was a
they show this island in the 50s
that's [ __ ] successful and it has
gambling and it has
music and bands are coming to play there
and you know it's just this i you know
the generations they don't know about
this even i that was closer to that
generation i forgot all about this
i tell you what it is making me do it's
making me hate castro again
oh really all over again like really
[ __ ] hate them do they just show news
clips what do they do they show they
have an actor
that's playing castro
and how
you know how they they took over homes
they went in there with a lie
but they went in there at the perfect
time lease i had
they went in there when batista was
making a mockery out of that island
you know batista didn't care about that
island for the last five years it was
italian controlled
you know it was mafia controlled those
casinos
and basically batista was just taking a
percentage and robin
he didn't give a [ __ ] jack and they
didn't give there's nothing they could
do
because what can they do if they kill
them
they had a they had another [ __ ] guy
to deal with
so batista did whatever the [ __ ] he
wanted to all those years
but at the same time he there was people
dying of starvation in cuba you know
when i was a child i heard these stories
when i got a little older i heard these
stories and i've seen the cubans in my
neighborhood
show the hatred they did for fidel
castro and i never could understand like
get over it watching this again makes me
understand why
it's really interesting what it's done
to me watch this show it also made me
understand something else
it made me understand something about
myself that you know what kept me alive
all those years when i was in the rocket
ship
and i went to jail and i was involved
with my ex-wife and the kid when i was
having all those problems you know what
kept me alive lisa what's that my faith
i swear to god i just realized that the
last couple last week or so
that's how much i believed as a young
man you know in catholicism
yeah just catholicism and the whole
belief that i was being watched that had
angels people watched over me
i really
did you abandon them
before like when you were doing all the
bad stuff
i abandoned that uh
i abandoned that
after the bad stuff after my mom passed
away i abandoned it because i lost
like i said before my belief system
that's when i abandoned it because i
couldn't believe it it would happen
you know
if there was a god that there was
all these great things well how could
this happen at this age
right
but it's
even like when did you get it back
because i would imagine it be a struggle
to deal with
doing some of the bad stuff and thinking
you're being watched
i would think it from time to time all
those years i probably got a little bit
of my faith back like in 2001 when i
started coming back
you know i've been thinking a lot lately
i've been writing a lot lately and it's
it's
it's really weird what love does to you
away and even though i tried to fight
terry off
terry gave me some faith for a couple
years there you know just a little bit
of faith and
i was shooting a short film
i was shooting this short film that
i went in there i have no [ __ ] idea
why i went in there
and i booked it it was a hundred dollars
a day
and they started breaking my balls right
off the bat
like we're gonna do rehearsals and i'm
like that's not gonna happen
what what's the problem i go to it's a
100 day film brother
i can't rehearse this [ __ ]
i rehearse on the [ __ ] set we when
we're blocking
we rehearse
he was a new director out of usa
he was by the book i had to break his
spirit right off the bat
was it was he still at usc was a student
he was just graduating but he was doing
something
and you know what i told him [ __ ] you i
was like i ain't doing it i told him in
the audition he goes you know if you
book this we're going to rehearse all
next week and i go how much does this
pay
cause it pays 100 hours a day and you
have three days on the setting what do
the rehearsals pay
he goes that's all part of the movie i
go i can't remember us for free
it was like i ain't rehearsing i ain't
going to be the [ __ ] burst
you were talking about your schedule
earlier i loved when you had that
meeting last week and you were talking
to the uh to the our friend at the bar
and you were just messing with him the
whole time
just like oh yeah i'll say i'll go until
the day out
he was having a heart attack
it really is the truth lee
i'm not lying to anybody no more i can't
do it
i can't do it
i'm too old and i don't have the [ __ ]
time
and especially when it involves a plane
you know there's just so many things
that
i just can't do i just won't do
you know when i'm sitting there and i'm
and i'm it's october
and you're talking to me about a
situation that's going to occur in april
i'll talk to you about it you sure right
yeah no come on
really you know i'll talk to you about
it
what am i gonna fit in i don't [ __ ]
know come back in march
huh
like is that what you say basically
yeah call me back in much i'll let you
know what's going on
that's it's fun for me now because i
know what your response is going to be
so whenever i see someone ask you a
question like that
it just makes me happy
oh yeah i even my agents know i'll tell
you whatever the [ __ ] you want to hear
the day of
that the you know while nothing's going
on once i wake up get up eat cereal i
don't really know if i'm taking that
right over the hill
then i really know
that i really decided what i'm about to
do is that [ __ ] important to me
what's the most important thing for me
to do today
is it really to go over a hill they got
a bad sandwich with some money to talk
about [ __ ] i've already heard anytime
not really
that gets canceled this gets canceled
this gets canceled this gets canceled
exact [ __ ] quick
people are always surprised when they
find out about like my work schedule
they're like so what am i going to do
like i haven't i don't know
we'll find out i'll find out next week
yeah we'll find out that we don't know
nothing about nothing about nothing
that's what makes this the most
interesting job in the world it's
actually kind of freeing
not having to worry about because that
you think you still would have freaked
me out before that would have given me
anxiety
i know it still does but listen
all you gotta do is look at my account
and go he's gone that weekend that
weekend i know i'm not working doesn't
work all that sometimes because
sometimes the gig it just goes away
you'll get i can you know you book
something or maybe like who knows once
in a while that happens once in a while
but so if you look at the two main
comedy club weeks of the month oh yeah
those are always solid yeah those are
true but then sometimes you change the
day you're leaving so i'll i'll no i'm
always leaving thursday i i've got it
down to it the funniest thing about me
is
they'll call me and they'll go listen
they like
and i'll give them the number
of the wednesday night flight like this
is late
do you understand me
so you'll tell them you're coming in
wednesday
sure i'll go
wow
you'll do the research to find out what
the wednesday night my number is you
know i don't [ __ ] around lady if you
don't
i even do red eyes if you don't catch it
once i send you
you're just that stupid
oh yeah and they're waiting for you at
the airport with the sign sure i just
haven't scheduled like eight
appointments sure guys yeah sports radio
go ahead drummond
go ahead
oh a podcast yeah sure i'll break my
[ __ ] rule this time pete i'll do a
pop once they ask me about the podcast
then i really pull the plug on them
then i give them to about 4 30 or 5
6 maybe
let's say if it's [ __ ] east coast
club right
i'll do it about
701 which is 1001 that time in the
morning at night oh at night okay okay
so they're going to bed already with the
pajamas i'm thinking they got to go to
berlin go get pick up joey diaz at the
[ __ ]
they think they gotta wake up
go see they're already asleep then they
probably have to wake up early they're
already asleep they're getting up at
five to go pick up joey at the [ __ ]
red eye and he just drops a bomb on him
they take the little snuggies off hello
joey what's going on listen
you're not gonna believe this
this can only happen to me
you always open up but you're not gonna
believe this and this only happened to
me i'm sitting here all [ __ ] week
scratching my balls sniffing my fingers
do you understand me nobody [ __ ]
gives a [ __ ] about me
just right now just right now what time
is it over there
it's 1001 it's 1007. yeah right now 10
to [ __ ] seven my time i just got a
call from a [ __ ] casting director
that they want me to audition for this
role tomorrow so what whoa whoa whoa
does that mean you're canceling the mark
come on would i do that to you
i talked her into putting it on tape
tonight but i gotta do it at nine
o'clock that's the only problem that
means i can't make the red eye [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't think i could schedule that
radio for you but listen it's already
three quarters sold out
wednesday what do we got thursday we got
210 all right then what are you worried
about we'll take some pictures they'll
go on twitter everybody's happy
and we'll sell out the weekend i need
your [ __ ] and then when he gets off
the phone there's no audition there's no
vertigo
there's no nothing
you're gonna have to start like keep
being keeping a list of all your excuses
so don't reuse them vertigo will last
forever i get vertigo whenever the check
ain't right something you know the same
whenever something right the check game
handy the check you start getting rid of
gold i said oh yeah yeah no no no let me
tell you something if they make me an
offer and it ain't right
i'll milk the offer to the day before
the week and i'll sell a bunch of
tickets
and then i'll call my agent and we'll
start working and listen call the club
and tell them joey's got vertigo you
don't know if he can make it he said he
just looked at the office for the first
time
your agent must hate seeing your phone
number pop up
he's like i'm gonna answer your calls on
wednesdays
it's always bad news
dog if i'm gonna pay him ten percent i'm
gonna make him hurt i'm worse than that
hasidic jew on the flight to [ __ ] lh
lax that time that work those [ __ ]
stewardesses i will work that agent to
death if he gets me for ten percent
i don't give a [ __ ] jack i'll make up
[ __ ] work i'll switch weeks on them
just to torment them
no no no you didn't need to switch the
weeks
the funniest thing was the funniest
thing was i call them
like in september so listen
i can't make you no promises but look at
those weeks after
the special i don't know how they're
gonna go he's like what are you talking
about what are you saying they go
i don't know
i might cancel all of that i can't
believe you at least gave him that
warning oh i go the wilbur might go
connecticut might go and they weren't
going nowhere i'm just torching them
just to let them know who the captain
kirk got the other prize
i'm whipping them i'm like you know what
i might do irvine but you might cancel
portland portland yeah we might cancel
portland i might just take the rest of
the [ __ ] hero for it
oh my god there's just silence when you
smoke weed do you get evil thoughts and
just call people please that's my
darkest thoughts when i'm sitting there
by myself it was a phone in the joint
and then i have to hear somebody talking
to me and bothering me and [ __ ] those
are my best [ __ ] moments when i'm
sitting there i could drop [ __ ] in my
head that'll put you down
and i even have it strategically when
and when i could call you what times
i could work you the whole night
[Music]
i was talking to paula because she's
like thinking of moving it she's moving
in a week or two
and she and i was like well yeah so joe
calls sometimes and she's like what time
does he call i'm like well
it could be two in the morning or six in
the morning
and i'm like
and she's like okay
i just put the cell phone on vibrant
it's always on vibrate but
it just
it's uh it's fun i am i almost missed
the 6 a.m phone calls
like you had me on that regimen for at
least a month i'll put you back on it
first thing tomorrow morning i'll put
you to the i'll put you to the front of
the line that's like ten to six that's a
good one right there
you have a schedule
first off
do you know the people that call me the
daytime from missiles with no with a
number
that i don't recognize
i call them at like 501 in the morning
they never pick up but they're baffled
of course it's five in the morning
4 35 around
and then i call you i call the people
like at six
years torment los angeles i give him
until six if i see red man
it's doing that [ __ ] periscoping
i give him whatever time he stopped
periscoping and i'll blast him right
there this house twice back to back
i'll make sure he answered that [ __ ]
phone even though so he went to bed at
like five i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna
call him at 6 30. i don't give a [ __ ]
if i know people are doing blow if i see
him on facebook and i think they're
doing blow i will call them and [ __ ]
why do you why do you need to torment
these people because you have to
there was a friend of mine that's a
comedian locally here and he would do
blow and go on twitter
and i would call him at like six
and just start tormenting his life about
[ __ ]
listen dawg i just got a call from the
cops i would [ __ ] torment him
i'm a professional this is what i enjoy
lee i don't have a lot of things that i
enjoy
this is you i take peace on
when
all the time when do you take your piece
on me listen if i get it i have larry as
my as my witness this weekend on the
other end of the phone calls he's like
that was hysterical when he was busting
your balls listen
you was i could put you in a [ __ ]
insane asylum i could put you on there
i'm like halfway there i've been
googling
doing some yelp researches listen to me
in 30 days i can put you insane aside
and asking questions
going in there [ __ ] dropping pink
floyd [ __ ] lyrics and [ __ ]
but i like it you're a good kid and i
don't get the satisfaction from cracking
it's people who think that genius is how
i like to crack
those are the ones that could put them
on the small low crack program
how many people have you sent to the
insane asylum
at least two or fifteen
they must know you then there must be
like a story of joey diaz
for the mental institutions
there's a kid on facebook
i was dear friends with him for a while
i loved him i loved him like a [ __ ]
brother i really didn't man
and
i don't know he just always felt like i
put something on him
he went to a therapist and talked about
it because years later he wrote me like
this known on [ __ ] facebook
you know you really messed with my head
i don't know we were kids what the [ __ ]
knew we were just playing around
oh i'm in for a lot of
mental therapy i i was actually thinking
about it to be honest with you what were
you thinking about i was thinking i've
never gone to therapy i've never done it
i was like [ __ ] i pay for this insurance
might as well test it out i wouldn't
talk to the lady see once i haven't
called yet once you call and you go down
there they put your name in the file and
then they ship your name again
to washington
now they put you in the loony bin all
right now you've been to the lily bin
one time don't mean that you've been to
lilyman
now they start sending you papagan in
the mail right because they know you're
half [ __ ] right
and they start sending you propaganda
and they ask you about them that's like
canada yeah about a national diet and
stuff like that
the next thing you know you're [ __ ]
this and your peanuts and you go shoot
the president you can't figure out what
made you go shoot the [ __ ] president
what made you go shoot the movie theater
i'm not shooting nobody that's what i'm
saying you're not going to believe you
go tell them you're crazy and they'll
make you crazy
you think so you don't recommend therapy
well i mean have you done it
when i went i never knew what therapy
was
it just sounded uh very distant to a guy
like me
especially a young age but
when i was in the halfway house
and i failed the blood a drug test they
put me back
at the halfway house and then when i
failed another drug test
they were gonna put me in jail thank god
i had a great attorney
who negotiated a six-week
stint
at a place called serenity which is now
the business
this thing went out of business 25 years
ago
so i put another business though no i
paid them and everything was great
because you couldn't get the certificate
until you paid them so for me to have to
pass this probation thing
i had to pay the certificate they [ __ ]
me but i didn't give a [ __ ]
they kept me out of jail it was six to
nine every [ __ ] night
five nights a week
six to [ __ ] night
so if you left work at five you gotta go
right to [ __ ]
did they stand up for you did what did
they have dinner for you they had a dick
for you
they had a break at seven
forty seven thirty you had a 15 minute
break to eat your dinner if you brought
it the women were very nice it was
i had never even gone to prison i could
sit here and tell you that i was put
into groups they never put me into
nothing
there was zero rehabilitation for me as
far as talking in there or anything like
that there was a.a meetings and n a
meetings
and there was a group that you
automatically paid for
whether you got something out of it or
not i went to that one
so yeah i might as well go but i didn't
go to anything else that i felt really
this was the first time
in this halfway house was the first time
where
i saw the effects
of therapy
you know and it started with uh
talking a conversation
it felt like we started talking about
the conversation and then they took that
conversation and used it against me
every word literally
now there's one thing about me
i'm not a literal guy
what do you mean by that
if somebody's sitting outside that wall
okay i could get the cops called on me
every [ __ ] night
you know when we're [ __ ] around you
and i
and i gonna leave do a bond hand or
you giggle like only come on eat another
mushroom or leave we're gonna eat a star
together
and you look at me and i just [ __ ]
around with you
and i just go lee eat that [ __ ] star
i'll stab me in the neck you and me
giggle
but there could be a guy out there
that takes that literally
and on down 9-1-1
and try to press charges or say he heard
it on many times
joey telling lee he was stabbing the
neck
right yeah it's just sort of along the
lines of anytime there's a scan a tape
recorded scandal that's always my
thought is that maybe like we don't know
you never know the whole story with that
sort of stuff
so
uh
i don't know about a tape recorded
scandal
i love being a team i mean i guess
maybe
who knows
the [ __ ] are we talking about
uh literal
being little so i go into this therapy
with these
so at the first thing you went there was
three people
with one therapist
and you talk about your life and blah
blah blah then the next day she came
back and just laid into you
well if your mother smoked pot do you
think this was the reason you would
smoke pot
i don't really know well think about it
what do you think it just became like
they they they would dig on you until
they found the scab
they would they would let you talk about
it
and then every time you your skin would
start to grow over that puncture wound
they would pick at it
that's what it felt like that was their
style of therapy that was their style or
whatever that's what i felt at that time
and i didn't think that i think that
there's some stuff sometimes
that's meant to stay under the carpet
i think that look right now at 53 man
if you want me to lie to you guys
there's times i remember shitty things i
did when i was [ __ ] 10
don't even have you guys know me and
i did [ __ ] when i was 10 and 8 i don't
have the courage to talk about now
you know that
it's not like i killed somebody or rape
somebody or something like that but this
is
creepy type [ __ ] you know that
i was dealing with
excuse me
excuse me i was doing with friends and
my mother's
kids
you know like they had daughters or
something and i would sleep over and me
and the kid you know we were young
we were [ __ ] young kids you know we
did creepy [ __ ] things you know
that was it that i'm kind of ashamed of
i mean it wasn't that bad but you're
kind of ashamed you didn't know you were
just a stupid [ __ ] kid you know
right
but uh
it comes back to
to [ __ ] with you or you have any dignity
if you have anything that you're made of
those little things always come back and
remind you you know
so now like
i'll tell you
when i was a kid my mom had a dry
cleaner
and she had a dry cleaner
with a guy named nelson rivera and his
wife delilah
they were really involved in numbers
since i think since the delilah and
nelson ran the dry cleaners they got
extra percentages from the dry cleaner
but my mom bought into the dry cleaner
it doesn't really matter
we were all really good friends nelson
my mom and my dad had gone back
to the 50s
it was now the 70s and they were still
friends dear friends nelson and my dad
had started a dry cleaner
and this is how the relationship
flourished
when my dad died my mom stayed friends
with him she sold her half but then
nelson opened up another dry cleaner in
the bronx and my mom bought into that
one
they had a daughter that was two years
older than me
she was two [ __ ] years older than me
and on the weekends sometimes
they were divorced nelson and the
girls
mother yeah so she would only get her
the other week so nelson would purposely
get her
and then bring me up there even though
she was two years younger than me i was
two years younger than her
she was older than i was well
i don't know how long i knew him
one day we started making out like
kissing creepily and i would pass out it
was [ __ ] terrible i didn't know what
i was doing i was embarrassed
and then i would suck on her titties i
mean we were like [ __ ] cousins and i
was sucking the titties and [ __ ] like
that we're in blood cousins
it wasn't like we're really causes not
at all i've never even
you don't think your parents were trying
to get you to get married or well not
the age of eight obviously not then but
but i remember she was old i'm exact i'm
exaggerating on the age because there
was one point we kept doing it and she
had hair on a [ __ ] already
and i had no hair we didn't have sex or
anything like that we were just kissing
well now i think about that because i
have a daughter
jesus okay yeah yeah that this is how it
repeats itself sometimes you're like ah
okay was i sexually harassing that girl
no what she says from her asking me no
they put us in a bed together
and on saturday mornings we'd wake up
early early early like at six in the
morning
at that time i had had like a little
heart on and she asked me what it was
one time and
from there on it was all over she never
sucked my dick and not nothing like that
we didn't have sex there was nothing
like that we were too young and too
innocent we kissed and i squeezed the
little boobies but in the first grade i
gave debbie debbie dominguez 50 [ __ ]
cents and she showed me a teddy's 50 a
quarter
me and like six other boys at the
playground we were in the first grade
i never paid anyone i don't i had a girl
who did sort of what your parents like
we had sleepovers like we had a fake
marriage once it was kind of where did
you i don't know probably our parents we
went to friendlies we got our own table
that's pretty cool
but uh oh [ __ ]
i think we might have been
like maybe eight and six maybe around
there maybe maybe probably not even that
maybe even five and four it was young it
was younger
and when did the marriage end how old
were you oh i did it immediately i mean
we were friends
but like i i guess probably as i got
older it was starting to get weird so
they probably were like you can't sleep
out that's probably at a certain age and
i guess it would probably stop being
cool for a boy and a girl to sleep over
i really i don't really remember how old
i was when i stopped though
but yeah probably around 10.
yeah that's a weird thing to have to
worry about as a dad i was such a
catholic kid that i don't think i could
i remember i felt guilty about that but
i didn't think i could have sex
as long as i didn't have sex i didn't
feel guilty
even at that age i had kind of deal with
myself but the next summer when i saw
her [ __ ] was hairy dog and i was like
in shock
and she's like let me show it to you now
with all the hair and i was like
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah i was i was too
young
i don't think i even knew about sex to
be quite honest with you i knew about it
i had heard about it but i was shy
towards it
it was just like kind of disgusting to
me but i like kissing people i don't
know
i like dancing and kissing women am i
like my dick getting hard and my head
getting all hot
so what the [ __ ] are you gonna do who's
that
who doesn't like all that
[ __ ] october it's gonorray ladies and
gentlemen
this means that tomorrow when you wake
up you're gonna start seeing
thanksgiving commercials and christmas
commercials there's already christmas
trees somebody said at one of the either
walmart or kmart or something they went
last week and there was already
christmas trees on [ __ ] sale so
there you have it this petrifies the
[ __ ] out of me this time of the year we
went to walmart and they were on on
halloween and they're already putting up
the uh christmas stuff
it was pretty crazy
well
this year went by super [ __ ] fast my
friends
super [ __ ] fast it's amazing
you sit here and you go that's it
i kind of i had to go home today and
take a nap after the joe rogan podcast
my [ __ ] ears were bleeding from all
the talking
it was ridiculous it was tremendous i
had a good time there but jesus christ
but uh
it's just you you can't believe it like
i was i look at things sometimes i'm
like you guys
i like to look at the camera and go wow
it's october 11th we got this much time
with lawson but we were just getting
excited about the special
i i know
and now it's gonna be here
okay once november hits it's a month and
a half away
yeah so in
two hours
wow
time has flown this year ladies and
gentlemen
by the way we got some interesting uh we
got some interesting new sponsors this
week here this one is the best one i
like this one so far
it's a great deal and i've asked larry
larry
uh
is a driver and i've asked him
uh
you know i gave lee
uh lee you've you've done lyft before oh
yeah i've i've driven and as a writer oh
you've driven and been a writer for lyft
absolutely and you've always uh talked
about lyft you still use left that's the
one i prefer
it's it's a nicer experience it's a it's
a friendlier experience
they've always they're always up front i
like that you can tip
you can tip these people that's a lot of
people like that you could tip remember
i asked you one time was no no it was in
new york i asked my nieces she's like no
they're already getting taken care of
i'd like to tell you about a smart way
to earn extra money and get an extra 500
bonus
drive for lift
okay are you in between jobs and looking
to earn extra money yeah it's [ __ ]
christmas trying you're looking to pay
money for your kids college fund i
[ __ ] hope so that shit's expensive
you're going back to school yourself you
get another degree huh on your first one
you're writing the next grace great
american novel you're seeking alternate
funding for your next startup planning
an exotic vacation tired of waiting
tables and you just love to drive do
yourself a favor drive for lyft the ride
sharing app that lets you be your own
boss pick your own hours and earn up to
15 hundred bucks a week driving your own
car okay
uh
there are other ride sharing apps out
there but everyone likes driving for
lyft because they treat their drivers
right lots of people started as
customers now they drive for lyft it's a
flexible way to make extra money anytime
from anywhere all you need is a car
driving for lyft pays up to 35 hours an
hour and getting started is fast and
easy you can drive mornings nights
weekends just flip into driver mode and
start making money plus
only lyft drivers can earn tips from
within the app those add up fast and you
don't have to wait days or weeks to get
paid you can cash out instantly with
express pay it all adds up it's super
flexible you keep your own tips and you
get paid when you need the extra cash
plus you make your own hours and you're
the captain kirk of the enterprise do me
a favor you're sitting around there with
a thumb in your ass you're not doing
nothing you bought that nice car now the
girl dumped you anyway now you don't
know what the hell to do i got an idea
for you let's make some extra dough
especially over the holidays why not
start the first with an extra couple
yard sticks in your pocket living like a
doctor sign up for
lyft.com
joey today and right now lyft has a
special offer for our listeners get this
a 500
new driver bonus when you sign up using
our show
just go to lyft.com
joey today so you can start making extra
guinness and get your 500
new driver bonus today that's lift.com
joey again that's lyft.com
joey listen you've been looking for a
job you can't [ __ ] find one what are
you gonna do sit there during the
holidays and be broke do yourself a
favor do me a favor do your family a
favor go to lyft.com joey today get a
nickel bonus go to lyft.com joey today
get a 500 bonus on us okay let me tell
you something when i had an opportunity
to work with these guys i had to jump on
it because a friend of mine had one of
these mbmt watches and i loved how it
looked the problem with me is i got this
gorilla ball and every time i get a
watch
they break i do something so i passed it
on to my goomba each lee
and he loves to watch that just goes to
show you we don't play games here on the
church what's happening now mvmt
watchers
pronounced the movement jack was founded
on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank and the
watchmaker's goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist
products and revolutionary prices with
over 500 000 watches sold to customers
in 160 plus countries around the world
mbnt watches has solidified itself as
the world's fastest growing watch
company all right they're on tv
radio these guys are savages as far as
lee's concerned you love the watch
correct oh yeah it's great it's light
it's it's it looks nice i really like
the black on black it's easy to tell the
time and it feel great and it looked
great with that black suit on absolutely
now the company started by two broke
college kids that wanted to wear stylish
watches but couldn't afford them so they
started their own watch company movement
watches started 95
at a department store you're looking at
400 to 500 bucks movement figured out by
selling online they were able to cut out
the middleman
and retail markup and providing the best
possible price classic design quality
construction and style minimalism over
500 000 watches sold in over 160
countries what we're going to do is this
it's the holidays get 15 off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
mvmt watches dot com slash church
c-h-u-r-c-h
this watch is really clean designed
seriously i've been getting compliments
uh lee's been getting compliments ever
since he put it on now is the time to
step up your watch game it's the
holidays you want to look good you want
to impress people at the parties go to
mvmtwatches.com
church join the movement jack you're
going to love these watches again go to
mvmtwatches.com
church you're gonna love this stuff all
right what do you think about that link
i love your watch and i'm happy you love
it don't forget on it's always there for
you they've been there for us every time
i fly the alpha brain the powder boom
boom boom
i'm back there's no jet lag i don't feel
like bella lugosi afterwards i'm ready
to sling dick and give out bubble gum
i'd also love to welcome
ziprecruiter.com okay a friend of mine
turned me on to these guys and he said
they were great are you hiring do you
know where to post your job to find the
best candidates
posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates all
right if you want to find the perfect
hire you need to post all your job on
all the top job sites and now you can
with ziprecruiter.com
you can post your job to 100 plus job
sites including social media networks
like facebook and twitter all
with a single click
find candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip
recruiters easy to use interface no
juggling emails or calls to your office
quickly screen candidates rate them and
hire the right person fast find out
today why zip recruiter has been used by
over 1 million businesses and right now
my listeners can post jobs on zip
recruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com
church again that's ziprecruiter.com
church one more time it's free go to
ziprecruiter.com
church okay
listen i'm not looking to hire somebody
but what i've heard is if i was looking
to hire somebody
this would be it so go to
ziprecruiter.com
and put in church and you can post any
job listing for free what do you think
about it
yeah it's a [ __ ] great deal if you
have a business you're looking for
people it's the holidays this is the
time of the year
don't forget me and leah will be at the
will bethina what's the date league the
11th 11-11
and then 11 12 we'll be at foxwoods
at 7 30 at night we'll be out of there
by nine maybe we can catch the last
fight in the ufc right there at the
casino that's how we roll [ __ ]
thank you for rolling with us this month
thank you for all the downloads this
month thank you for helping us out with
the uh taping
listen i i love all you guys without you
[ __ ] we wouldn't have nothing
we figured it was halloween it was gonna
be a dead [ __ ] uh
thing we'll be back wednesday or
thursday morning with a new podcast all
right see you then
don't forget about us next friday at the
wilton and saturday night
at the foxwoods country club
are you looking at me all weird for like
i owe you 22 dollars
i don't know
[Music]
[Music]